glad to make your acquaintance recruits
the lucky few of you accepted to the
Pathfinder team will be flying with me
I'm callow Jenna and this is the tempest
I've been here pilot since the early
prototype days so take my word when I
tell you that she's light stealthy and
easily the fastest ship in our class
capable of doing 13 light years per day
of course all that speed comes with some
sacrifice
she isn't weighed down by heavy armor or
a main gun but rest assured anything we
can't outrun we'll have a tough time
finding us between missions Pathfinder
team will call the tempest home and
everything in our home is
state-of-the-art our research room is
available for R&D needs this will be the
space for gathering Intel and samples
we've acquired and working out their
practical application in upgrading
everything from weapons to armor to the
Nomad Scout Rover it's all supported by
discoveries from the tech and vial labs
aboard the meeting room gives us a place
to gather the crew or videoconference
with the Nexus below our engineering The
Tempest armory med bay and the cargo bay
which houses the nomad
during your downtime you can relax in
the crew quarters or the galley the
Pathfinders cabin is also located nearby
but is off-limits to the general crew
unless invited of course my place is on
the bridge this is where the Pathfinder
operates our nav system synced
specifically to them any destination at
the Helius cluster right at their
fingertips
we verify ground conditions with our
scanners the tempest will enter the
atmosphere touchdown and the team will
head out in the Nomad for a closer look
this Rover is the definition of
all-terrain with twin hydrogen oxygen
fuel cells powering an element zero core
independent suspension for each wheel
and interchangeable four or six wheel
drive she comes equipped with a rear
fuel injection boost to propel you
forward and in any tight spots helium 3
micro thrusters beneath the vehicle are
on hand to blast you clear the Nomad
must be able to adapt to difficult
conditions the modularity of its design
allows everything from thrusters shields
she blasts life-support radar and of
course paint jobs to be customized based
on our surroundings and most crucial of
all is your ability to scan planet
surfaces for valuable resources and mind
them with deployable mining drones we
have an entire galaxy to scout recruits
the next time I welcome you onboard the
tempest I hope to do so as crew mates
see you in Andromeda